[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv
60,18 bienvenue pour cette édition du 7
8 journal tout de suite les titres de ce
lundi 11 mars
les obsèques d'andré damien ce matin à
versailles une messe se dérouler en la
cathédrale saint-louis plusieurs
personnalités étaient présentes pour un
dernier adieu à l'ancien élu décédé la
semaine dernière il a été le maire de la
ville pendant 18 ans entre 1977 et 1995
lo ng saint-quentinoise eden installer
des panneaux photovoltaïques à kona
village au centre dumas l'est du mali un
projet mise à mal par la guerre qui
sévit dans le pays une nouvelle phase
d'installation doit débuter cette
semaine une délégation malienne et à
elancourt pour rencontrer des
partenaires nous en parlons avec nos
invités
et puis la course au soleil a quitté les
yvelines le paris nice a débuté ce
week-end les deux premières étapes
étaient au départ du département hier
depuis saint germain en laye aujourd'hui
des bréviaires retour dans ce journal
sur ce plateau également tout à l'heure
la sophrologue valérie gaudin pour
parler d'un événement autour de la
sophrologie et de la plongée en apnée
c'est ce samedi à conflans sainte
honorine
ce chiffre pour débuter 30 30% de
signalements d'agression sexuelle en
plus dans les transports en ile de
france en 2018 constat du dernier
rapport de la préfecture de police de
paris a révélé par nos confrères du jdd
une hausse qui peut s'expliquer par une
libération de la parole des femmes qui
osent davantage dénoncé lé transport
lieu principal où les femmes sont
victimes de violence dans la région est
la ratp et la sncf ont mis en place un
numéro d' alerte le 31 17 joignable
également par sms 24 heures sur 24 et 7
jours sur 7
les obsèques aujourd'hui d'andré damien
celui qui a été le maire de la ville de
versailles pendant 18 ans s'est éteint
mardi dernier à l'âge de 89 ans une
messe s'est déroulée ce matin en la
cathédrale saint-louis plusieurs
personnalités politiques avaient fait le
déplacement le reportage daury les 11
[Musique]
jean louis debré gérard larcher ou
encore valérie pécresse
ils avaient tous côtoyé de près andré
damien et sont venus lui rendre un
dernier hommage en la cathédrale
saint-louis avocats mais aussi homme
politique l'homme décédé le 5 mars
dernier à l'âge de 89 ans fut le premier
magistrat de la ville de versailles de
1977 à 1995
l'une de ses réalisations marquantes le
sauvetage du marché notre dame
je crois qu'il versait mais aussi le
souvenir que c'est le maire qui a sauvé
le marché et donc chaque fois que les
versailles est bon sur le marché peut se
souvenir que maître damien a beaucoup
oeuvré pour la rénovation ce marché
après si c'est une occasion de lui dire
notre reconnaissance comme élus locaux
nous savons bien que nous ne sommes que
les continuateurs de quelque chose qui a
commencé avant nous et il a marqué cette
ville d'une empreinte définitive une
personnalité qui aura donc marqué
l'histoire de la ville de versailles
de son côté la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse se
souvient d'un homme profondément
humaniste avec une très grande liberté
de ton
j'étais
un bébé d'amiens comme il y en a eu
beaucoup dans les yvelines c'est à dire
qu'il m'avait pris sous son aile et il
était avec moi au conseil d'état il
m'avait mis pied à l'étrier quand je
suis arrivée au département il avait eu
d'ailleurs le courage de me soutenir
mois la jeune femme entrée en politique
face aux pontes de son parti un homme
attentif aux personnes qui étaient dans
le besoin et qui ne manquait pas
d'humour comme l'a rappelé monseigneur
éric aumônier tout au long de la messe
[Musique]
autre réaction à vous proposer celle de
gérard larcher présent aussi ce matin
pour les obsèques d'andré damien le
président du sénat qui était déjà à
versailles vendredi pour une visite de
la ville
je n'oublie pas que j'ai été le vice
président de l'union des maires coeur
andré damien était le président des
maires de ce département
c'était quelqu'un qui avait une vision
il s'encombrait pas de l'accessoire et
il disait d'ailleurs voyez larcher pour
l'accessoire
mais je veux dire j'ai beaucoup appris
et en même temps il avait une vision il
avait une parole
il avait en même temps un engagement
personnel qui fait que ce qu'il a sur
son épée d'académicien souligne bien son
attachement à versailles son attachement
à marianne et quelque part son
attachement aussi est-ce qu'il était
profondément le bâtonnier le bâtonnier
andré damian le conseiller d'état
andré damien et celui aussi qui a été
parlementaire mais surtout le maire
le cdh huile exceptionnel rappelez vous
c'était en juin dernier les locaux de sj
à plaisir été ravagés par les flammes
depuis pas de réouverture du site
l entreprise spécialisée dans le
traitement de pièces pour l'aéronautique
souhaite délocaliser son activité sur
son second site à villers cotterêts dans
l'aisne une décision annoncée aux
représentants du personnel par sms et
qui ne passe pas auprès des 78 salariés
ils ont saisi les prud'hommes de
versailles pour demander le maintien de
leur emploi dans les yvelines la séance
se tenait vendredi mais les conseillers
du tribunal n'ont pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord
un magistrat professionnel va être nommé
pour trancher sur le dossier dans les
prochaines semaines une action
humanitaire à présent au mali l ong eden
basée à saint quentin en yvelines à
installer des panneaux photovoltaïques à
caunes à kaunas est un village situé au
centre du mali dans la région de mopti
au bord du fleuve niger alors pour en
parler quatre invités autour de cette
table il ya sylvie soyez bonsoir vous
êtes secrétaire d'éden également
président l'ancien président et
fondateur de cette ong jacques maréchal
mon soir bonsoir
et nous avons également deux invités qui
nous viennent de cauna au mali nous
avons le maire ousmane campo bonsoir et
vous avons nous avons également sur ce
plateau youssouf nadio bonsoir vous êtes
technicien en charge du photovoltaïque à
kona alors vous êtes cette semaine sur
saint quentin en yvelines pour
rencontrer des partenaires afin de
soutenir un troisième projet
d'installation de panneaux des
précédents projets ont été mises à mal
par la guerre qui sévit au mali depuis
2012 malgré des accords de paix alors
avant d'en parler un petit mot peut être
déjà sur l' ong et dance est une ong qui
a été créée en 2008 et ses missions ont
évolué avec le temps
démarrée sur des problématiques locales
et puis nous avons défilé nous consacrer
à la coopération décentralisée et de
nous poser au mali en particulier à
connard puisque historiquement saint
quentin en yvelines et en particulier
mon repas à une action au mali à mopti
au travers d'actions mopti depuis 85 je
crois et donc c'était un complément
d'une activité qu'il n'avait pas puisque
son sur l'éducation sont sur les forages
et s'éteint et la santé donc ce
complément énergie était naturellement
bénéfique et elle est au service de ses
trois activités en complément si je puis
dire ce que vous soyez ça fait partie
des actions déployées à à kona
l'installation de panneaux photo
voltaïques alors qu'ils fonctionnent en
échange d'une mini rétribution et qui
servait à alimenter le village de
pêcheurs de daya kona des écoles et
aussi des centres de santé c'est ça oui
c'était notre projet initial c'est de
d'installer des panneaux mais uniquement
à la demande de nos amis de cauna et et
de demander aux personnes à qui en
installer des panneaux de rétribuer la
mairie à la fois pour permettre de
racheter deux futurs panneaux de
permettre l'entretien des panneaux
existants et et pour cet entretien nous
avions participé à la formation de de
monsieur youssouf nadio qui est là et
qui est maintenant j'ai oublié de vous
le dire
conseiller municipal celui ci dans la
même et qui colle ici donc nous avons
fait deux représentants de la de la
mairie de caunes on va parler de cette
formation monsieur nez à dio dans un
instant juste dire avant que ce projet
de panneaux que vous aviez installé au
mali a souffert à cause de la guerre qui
qui sévit depuis 2012 qu'on a d'ailleurs
été le théâtre d'une bataille c'était en
janvier 2013
panneaux quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui ousmane quand paul et les
panneaux ont été endommagés non les
panneaux ne sont pas endommagées c'est
seulement au niveau des bactéries connu
des problèmes de la commune sont foutu
mais au niveau des panneaux ça va et
aujourd'hui il faut un nouveau projet
c'est essentiel pour pour connaître
vraiment c'est nécessaire d'avoir un
nouveau projet par rapport à
l'électricité
quelle importance à d'avoir justement
ces panneaux photovoltaïques ses
batteries également à cosnac l
importance pour pour les habitants de
connaître très très important car on
sait bien qu'avec les lampes à pétrole
ça peut causer pas mal de complications
des domaines santé d'accès dock avec eux
vraiment c'est photovoltech on va
vraiment s'épargner de tout cela pour la
santé pour les écoles ya également une
utilité pour les commerces qui peuvent
fonctionner en soirée les artisans ci
qui peuvent travailler à la lumière de
la numéro 7 13 important à ce niveau et
donc vous le disiez tout à l'heure
sylvie soyez ya des techniciens qui ont
été formés grâce à ce projet des
techniciens sur le photovoltaïque c'est
votre cas youssouf nadio vous avez été
formé sur cette technologie
ces singes étaient faux bond avec comme
si elles dénient nous a informé la porte
aux photos voir parce qu'à l'époque les
photovoltaîque n'est pas très nombreux
chez nous au mali
mais avec la formation qu'on a réussi
avec chez denis ça nous a permis
comment faire les échanges et puis
encore comment l'entretenir le sait
photovoltaïque
et puis comment il faut encourager les
autres aussi pour des événements tout le
monde s'investit au photovoltaïque comme
le mal vient de dieu lumière là c'est
très très très important chez nous on
utilisait de l'importateur d'accord avec
notre formation ça nous a permis
seulement aujourd'hui y'a pas de mal de
photovoltaïque dans notre commune qui
écoutent du coin cette formation vous
avez suivi directement à bamako encore
oui combien de temps ça va durer cette
formation qui joue une formation qui est
importante qui est que faut-il
aujourd'hui du coup sur place à kona bon
aujourd'hui à cannes à nos
photovoltaïque marchait très bien
les a donnés des redevances bon avec la
guerre bon tu sais ça n'a pas marché
parce que les utilisons l'outil la
mairie n'a pas de moyens les charrs et
ses batteries avec ce problème là bon
cela pose et d'encore la mairie m'a rien
dit des sources aujourd'hui depuis
l'émetteur est ce qu'un jour je vous dis
que la mairie n'a aucune ressource
ça c'est depuis qui a eu cette bataille
sur place à kaunas et c'est ça qui a
fait changer cela changeait tout d'r
nous depuis le maire passé les têtes
raides rate jamais parce que les
djihadistes ont menacé les villageois
secula chef de village
gallas et l'équipe et c'est taxer c'est
un appel que ce conflit armé en eau
mallié oppose notamment les forces
maliennes à des groupes des groupes
islamistes et aussi des forces touareg
mais voilà ça c'était au tout début du
conflit que faut-il haut du coup
aujourd'hui cessé de mener
jacques marie jeanne un troisième projet
un troisième projet dans le cadre du
photovoltaïque et j'y arrive juste une
précision il nommé monsieur denis il
faut savoir que monsieur denis c'est
notre ingénieur d'éden qui est allé au
départ analyser les besoins précis des
maliens sur place et puis qui est revenu
pour faire la formation d'accord des
maliens photovoltaïque stu précision je
pense est important alors aujourd'hui
notre propos est on en sort de discuter
ensemble c'est de remettre en état
a minima les installations et également
de passer à la troisième tranche de
notre opération qui sera une partie de
continuité de ces kits photovoltaïques
dans les maisons individuelles et puis
de se consacrer à aux écoles donc
l'objectif en deux mots c'était
d'échanger sur ce sujet l'objectif de
leur vie ici et de faire notre plan de
projets d'investissement pour les 2 3
ans qui viennent et puis après nous
irons à la recherche des financements
merci à vous quatre d'être passé d'un
plateau très rapidement ce qu'on arrive
à la fin très rapidement un petit regret
toutefois il nous avions un partenaire
sûr qu'ils étaient l'intercommunalité de
saint quentin en yvelines qui depuis
deux ans s'est désengagé des
financements de la coopération
décentralisée et nous le regrettons
merci jacques maréchal mais nous avons
rendez vous demain avec monsieur têtards
qui est le haut conseil général
départemental le conseil départemental
des yvelines et avec qui nous espérons
continuer ce projet de coopération
décentralisée ainsi si vous soyez jeune
maréchal merci eden et ousmane campo et
youssouf nadio du viège de cauna
bienvenue à vous ici et on aura
l'occasion d'en dire plus sur ce sujet
de suivre l'évolution de ce projet sur
le photovoltaïque transformer des atomes
faire se déplacer des électrons au
programme des trophées régionaux de la
robotique samedi dernier pour la
quatrième année consécutive l'événement
se déroulait à la ferme du manet à
montigny le bretonneux avec une
quarantaine d'équipés venues de toute
l'île de france manon varaldo et mélanie
poké bienvenue à montigny échos city une
ville 100% en matériaux recyclés un
projet créé par des jeunes ni mon temps
à l'occasion des trophées régionaux de
la robotique
on n'a rien acheté pour fabriquer la
maquette jusqu'à la guirlande qui a été
récupéré
au niveau des encombrants et de ça donc
voila et
des briques de lait qui nous ont servi
donc à faire les immeubles et on a
travaillé donc autour de ce projet avec
une centrale nucléaire qui est gardé par
un dôme indestructible et qui permet
donc de d'éviter les retombées
radioactives
je trouvais que c'était intéressant de
toucher à l'électronique aussi
l'électrique et de bricoler 37 équipes
ont participé à cette édition des jeunes
de 7 à 18 ans issus de toute l'île de
france
organisée par planète sciences le
trophée de monde plusieurs mois de
préparation
le thème cette année at home factory ça
permet de toucher à beaucoup de choses
que ce soit de l'électronique pour
certains ça peut même aller par des
petites notions de programmation et ils
travaillent sur leurs robots en équipe
donc ça fait aussi travailler avec les
autres travailler à plusieurs et 7 se
développe aussi des petites compétences
de bricolage il lésigny montain
repartent de cette édition avec le prix
éco citoyen les vainqueurs eux ont
rendez vous les 6 et 7 avril pour la
finale nationale à saint quentin dans
l'aisne
[Musique]
comme tous les lundis la chronique sport
de mika et demi d'euros qui est à ma
gauche ce soir bon sens mais quelle est
la soeur grégory alors ce week-end se
déroulait la 77e édition du paris-nice y
avait également une étape au départ ce
matin une course au soleil qui est parti
depuis saint germain en laye dimanche
c'est un peu la tradition dans les
yvelines depuis dix ans le département
accueille le départ de l'épreuve au mois
de mars
et cette année c'est saint germain en
laye qui a été retenu pour cette course
au soleil ils étaient plusieurs milliers
pour assister à la présentation des 23
équipes et des 161 coureurs devant le
château ce dimanche on pouvait
apercevoir des colombiens des
australiens des britanniques dans le
public mais également à des supporters
locaux
un père et son fils était au micro de tv
78 c'est chouette on voit les coureurs
de près pourquoi voilà on est là pour
les encourager et puis c'est une belle
course qui s'annonce
c'est une concession importante parce
que
nous n'aurons mondiale et y ait des
comptoirs et
on évolue à gagner il ya des grands
enjeux aussi pour l'addition après un
peu plus de trois heures de course dans
le département des yvelines et 138 5 km
c'est le néerlandais dylan grenouille
gan qui s'impose sur le fil devant
khaled et wan et fabio jakobsen nous
avons recueilli sa réaction juste après
l'arrivée c'était très plaisant de
gagner aujourd'hui aussi d'obtenir le
maillot jaune ce sera sympa de le porter
ce maillot jaune demain aujourd'hui
c'était une étape très dure avec
beaucoup de vent mais l'équipe a fait du
très bon travail avec qu'est six
coureurs dans le premier groupe avec un
point nous restons devant donc c'est
très bien pour l'équipe et pour moi
d'avoir gagné aujourd'hui vous m'ayez
d'attributs maintenant un très beau
vainqueur je vais voir si j'arrive à le
prononcer mieux que vous michael dylan
grenoble guns et ça je peux pas vous
confirmer
difficile à dire en tout cas si les
carrières vainqueur et le lendemain de
ce tout ce tout beau monde ce tout le
monde s'est retrouvé au bréviaire
c'était aujourd'hui ce matin c'est ça un
petit village de 1300 habitants qui a
reçu les plus grandes stars du cyclisme
sur route c'est insolite et pourtant les
bréviaires l'on fait ce lundi matin le
village il a dix septième ville du
département organiser un départ du paris
nice et c'est surtout une grande
première pour la commune on écoute les
réactions au micro de tv 78
pourquoi les premières balles et
brebières parce que le sait c'est un
endroit qui était bien sympathique moi
qui m'entrainait dans le secteur je
passais souvent brevière parce qu'il y
avait le haras des bréviaires il ya
toujours le haras des bréviaires et je
trouvais ce petit village de fort
sympathique mais on a besoin de montrer
aussi aux coureurs
au public que les courses de vélo
peuvent s'organiser dans les petits
villages dans les grandes villes bien
évidemment mais aussi dans les petits
villages ont transporté champions ici le
l'élite du cyclisme mondial et
aujourd'hui aux premières plus petit
village de le départ de paris-nice donc
c'est pas rien ah oui c'est une surprise
d'accueillir ça dans un petit village
comme le dos très clairement c'est
positif regarder le monde qui les
entoure et tous les habitants je crois
ont séché leurs journées de travail pour
pour être ici les coureurs se sont
ensuite installés sur la ligne de départ
pour cette dernière est à cette étape
263 5 km jusqu'à bellegarde dans le
loiret les sportifs ont parcouru 41,5 km
dans les yvelines avant de le quitter et
des kits de quitter le département à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines le paris-nice
heures reviendra l'année prochaine dans
les yvelines dans le cadre de son
partenariat avec le département la
course au soleil fêtera en 2020 sa 78ème
édition
tout un symbole merci michael le paris
nice auquel vous consacré d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure une émission est quasi
entière dans votre 7,8 sport c'est une
édition spéciale a retrouvé après ce
journal sur tv 78 autres compétitions
d'envergure peut être même la plus
grande du cyclisme sur route le tour de
france passera également par le
département cet été dernière étape au
départ de rambouillet et direction les
champs elysées dimanche 28 juillet et on
en sait plus sur le tracé yvelinois de
la grande boucle le départ sera donné
aux alentours de 18h 10 devant le
château de rambouillet avant de se
diriger vers les communes des bréviaires
du perray-en-yvelines ou encore de
cerner la vie la vallée de chevreuse
sera à l'honneur avec un passage sur la
mythique côte des dix sept tournant au
total 50 des 128 kilomètres de cette
dernière étape du tour de france
passeront par les yvelines allez après
le sport et les forts un peu de bien
être avec ma nouvelle invité valérie
gaudin bonsoir vous êtes sophrologue
professionnels pâte praticienne en
hypnose et vous êtes la présidente de la
société vale sens qu'ils consultent
notamment à à feucherolles maisons
laffitte et au vésinet samedi prochain
vous co organisé une journée sophrologie
est plongée en apnée c'est au programme
au centre aquatique est de conflans
sainte honorine on va présenter cet
événement dans un instant déjà la
sophrologie pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas cette pratique quel est le principe
de la sophrologie
on appelle la sophrologie une pratique
psychocorporelle c'est à dire qu'on va
chercher à retrouver un équilibre entre
le mental et le corps lorsque vous
faites une crise angoisse lorsque vous
avez une montée de stress notamment pour
une équipe une épreuve sportive votre
corps va réagir a principalement des
pensées que vous pouvez avoir
donc on va essayer de jouer sur les deux
dimensions pour retrouver un mieux-être
et faire en sorte que les choses se
passent de manière plus calme et plus
posé quand at on besoin de sophrologie
ça peut être dans de nombreuses
circonstances ça peut être simplement
pour traverser des moments difficiles de
la vie ça peut être dans le cadre d'une
maladie lourde ou moins lourdes ça peut
être aussi ben justement dans la
préparation mentale lors de pratiques
sportives de l'examen de permis de
conduire ce genre de choses
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
peut être utile au quotidien ou de
manière ponctuelle lors d'événements
particuliers
et justement quels sont les bienfaits de
la sophrologie retrouver une meilleure
gestion de son stress retrouver des
sensations qui sont un peu plus apaisé
retrouver un mieux être en général et
surtout reprendre le contrôle et de son
corps et de ses réactions et aussi de
ses pensées est ce que c'est une méthode
de travail qui est aujourd'hui reconnue
puisque de plus en plus au départ la
sophrologie était surtout dans le milieu
médical puisque c'est un neuropsychiatre
qui l'a mise en place
puis elle est sortie du milieu médical
dans le milieu sportif maintenant elle
est beaucoup utilisé dans le milieu des
entreprises énormément dans le quotidien
et de nombreux médecins par exemple
m'envoie des patients à eux pour les
aider à surmonter certaines difficultés
je disais tout à l'heure vous êtes
également praticienne en hypnose est ce
qu'il ya un lien avec la sophrologie
c'est très proche c'est très proche moi
j'utilise les deux techniques lorsque
évidemment les personnes sont d'accord
pour surmonter des traumatismes du passé
certaines difficultés
les deux feront appel un état de
conscience modifiée donc ça permet de
travailler sur des choses qui sont un
petit peu plus profonde mais de manière
beaucoup plus douce mais on vous
proposait une journée sophrologie est
plongée en apnée
est ce qu'il ya un lien entre les deux
donc ça se déroule samedi à conflans
sainte honorine
est ce qu'il ya un lien entre
sophrologie est plongée en apnée a
priori comme ça les personnes sans
surprise mais il ya un très fort lien on
avait déjà fait sur tout un week-end ce
type d'atelier et pour les apnéistes qui
étaient là qui était déjà confirmés ils
ont eux mêmes été très surpris par
justement la dimension mentale de leur
sport qu'ils avaient forcément pris en
compte mais peut-être pas à ce point là
et ça permet de faire de la préparation
mentale soit pour tenir d apnée statique
plus longtemps soit éventuellement pour
descendre plus profondément et obtenir
des records personnels quoi donc les le
principe de la journée finalement c'est
de se rendre compte que la sophrologie
peut aider dans cette pratique de la
veille ça on va alterner sophrologie en
salle préparation par de la relaxation
musculaire de la visualisation notamment
des plongées à venir et puis ensuite on
va faire de la sophrologie en bassin je
vais leur faire faire une relaxation
dans l'eau et puis ensuite descendre
soit d'abord faire de l'apnée en
statique pour ceux qui veulent rester le
plus longtemps donc sans respirer sous
l'eau
et puis faire de la sophrologie aussi
pour permettre à près de descendre le
plus profondément possible ce à partir
de 14 ans est ce que ça s'adresse à tous
qu'on soit initiée à la plongée pas du
tout le monde il ya des débutants des
confirmés on avait vraiment les deux les
deux publics la dernière fois et puis là
on risque même d'avoir des personnes qui
ont des difficultés un peu physique ou
qui ont souffert de maladies lourdes
donc on
bien sûr la nécessité d'avoir un
certificat médical mais sinon c'est
vraiment ouvert à tous il faut
s'inscrire à l'avancé
il faut s'inscrire le plus tôt possible
la effectivement et c'est une journée
qui sera au tarif de 199 euros 10 euros
pour la journée
oui avec un apnéiste de haut niveau et
moi en s'offrant et toutes les
informations sur cette journée à
retrouver bien sûr sur le site internet
qui s'est affichée durant cet entretien
merci et valérie gaudin d'être passé sur
ce plateau sophrologue et praticienne en
hypnose un salon entièrement dédié à
l'univers du vinyle avant de refermer ce
journal vinyle expo est venu pour la
première fois à versailles tout le
week-end les visiteurs ont pu fouiller
leur bac les bacs à la recherche de
perles rares retours avec manon varaldo
et marylène yapi chinon de la musique
avec le son chaud du vinyle au sein de
l'hôtel de ville de versailles
ce week-end les amateurs de l'univers du
disque microsillon se sont donné rendez
vous à cette quatrième édition de
vinexpo
on est dans la musique depuis x années
on a vu qu'il y avait un retour du
vinyle qui n'a jamais cessé d'exister et
on a décidé de faire quelque chose qui
ne soit pas une convention
c'est à dire de réunit le vinyle les
disquaires nationaux internationaux et
l'univers du vinyle le matériel high
tech le matériel vintage des lampes en
vinyle dans des lieux prestigieux que
sont les mairies un jukebox moderne des
objets de décoration et encore du
matériel high tech
une soixantaine d'exposants étaient
présents pour plonger les visiteurs
venus nombreux dans cet univers du
vinyle ça nous permet de rencontrer
plein de noms mais on
une visibilité supplémentaire c'est la
troisième fois qu'on travaille avec la
vie de l'expo justement on a été à
levallois est à se demander où ça s'est
super bien passé donc on continue
as tu veux
sur la lancée d'une île et que dès
l'ouverture avoir du mal à trouver ses
vinyles près de faire et je pense que
c'est plutôt rassurant
rassurant pour le marché de mine il est
rassurant pour notre métier
pour avoir de patikul les disquaires ont
envahi l'espace de leur bac ne restait
plus qu'à fouiller pour dénicher des
pépites de tous les styles musicaux il
ya du choix et c'est agréable de pouvoir
chercher et devoirs on peut trouver des
choses intéressantes c'est bien durant
ce week-end plus de 6000 visiteurs se
sont réchauffées les oreilles au vinexpo
à versailles c'est la fin du set 8
journal merci de l'avoir suivi une
édition à retrouver bien sûr sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]